hey everybody and in this video I just
want to quickly collect all of my
thoughts and impressions about planets
ooh
specifically the ones that I got during
Gamescom while I was doing my streams
and also recorded the footage that
you're looking at right now which I was
not allowed to release until the day
before yesterday
I'm a little bit late with this one but
anyway let's just get it on I want to
make this video as a kind of summary of
all of my thoughts to try and do
something unique with this compared to
some of the other streamers who have
gotten the same looks into the game that
I have gotten so I'll just go through
all of my thoughts and well my main
ideas and we'll see what comes out of it
it's a bit of a recap of my streams as
well I'm not a very good streamer and
these videos take a while to go through
so I figured it would be good to have a
more condensed presentation of my
thoughts in this video I also should
note that I'm probably a bit biased
there are no payments or whatsoever
going from frontier my way but at the
end of the day they're treating all of
us all of the people they're inviting to
stream or do whatever with their games
even come up to the community events in
Cologne they're just treating everybody
way too nicely so as much as I want to
try to be objective I'm probably biased
in a few ways still those who know me
know that I've always been really
critical of planet coaster see for
instance the schematics podcasts or the
whole incident that got me in contact
with the devs I was reminded by Dale who
used to be community manager at frontier
that the only reason that I actually
managed to get into contact with the
developers is because I caught the game
absolute [ __ ] on the planet coaster
subreddit discord server so I don't know
maybe something will come of critiquing
pl'anna too but I'm just gonna try and
present my thoughts
as honestly as possible here also my
perspective is someone who doesn't have
expertise in animals per se I'm just
interested mostly in scenery theming
architecture for
those kinds of things that's where I'd
say I can come in with actual unique
things to say and with some decent
expertise and when it comes to animals
I'm just about the average person so I'm
not going to comment too much on that
because I don't think I'm a of authority
per se on that matter
anyway I wasn't too much into theme
parks before rollercoaster tycoon 3 and
I really I didn't even dare to ride
rollercoasters until planteth coasters
so maybe I'll get much more into zoos at
some point but at this point it's not
something that I want to speak about too
in-depth before I make any mistakes or
anything like that anyway that's all the
things that I wanted to say gone now
moving on to my actual thoughts about
the game there's one thing that I really
want to put a lot of focus on the one
aspect of the game that honestly
surprised me the most then I found most
promising and quite unique and yeah it's
really probably my the thing that I'm
most hyped about it's just how physical
all of the scenery objects are I think
when it comes to simulation games like
this it's always been a struggle to
manage creativity on one hand and
gameplay or strategy on the other
because these kind of games come with a
framework of constraints creative play
where you have to juggle limits of
management's with the creative freedom
of artistic expression and it's it's
always just a major challenge and in
planet coaster for instance I think
scenery has always been kind of an
invisible decoration it has a limited
uses scenery value but it doesn't really
interact much with anything else in the
game and overall it's just very much a
game that most people play for the sake
of scenery and then on the other hand
you've got games like the original
rollercoaster tycoon
which most people play really focused on
the management side of things and the
thing is in a lot of games I think it's
it's a bit of a trade-off between
scenery versus management focus and
making stuff look good
versus making stuff work well I've
always been kind of separate things but
I think in Planet Zoo so far what I
really like is just how incorporated
scenery is in gameplay and management
aspects of the game because it is so
physical so for one the scenery is
interacted with so you'll have animals
that climb on climb aboard props like
like all the monkeys will use climbing
bars that you can build piece by piece
and they'll actually interact with it
and climb in different ways like the
mandrels over here in this park of the
the preview built that I managed to play
here which is absolutely amazing and
it's not even just the climb of all
props I think this is something to also
be clarified animals will climb on just
about anything if it's climb about
reasonably I think I don't see any
reason not to assume so because I've
seen them climb on pretty much any
object that you throw at them it's just
that the specific objects which are in
the climb above object section are used
to fulfill the climbing needs of the
animals but still monkeys will climb in
trees all the animals will climb onto
rocks maybe even sleep there or do
whatever they'll interact with different
kinds of scenery pieces in a different
way which is really cool and what's also
kind of interesting is that on my last
live stream in Gamescom I was building a
tiger temple and I had some logs leading
into the temple and then inside the
temple was all of the bedding and I even
noticed that a staff member who walked
those logs into this temple to the
bedding so even the staff members can
use scenery to walk to certain places
the same goes for the lady signer she
built an island for her lemurs and had
some wooden bridges again on the island
and these bridges weren't the kind of
scenery objects where you look at it and
you're like right the stuff can clearly
walk in that of course but at the end of
the day one staff member eventually
cross those bridges to clean poop of the
islands so that was really cool
as well I only kind of regret not
testing scenery on guest parts because
I'm not sure to what extent the same
goes for guest parts because guests
while wayfinding is probably a bit
different from stuff and animals but
that's something to see later anyway the
second thing that I thought was really
interesting about scenery is that it
affects animal needs which I have to
admit is of course a bit of a no-brainer
for zoo game of course but I think it's
really well executed here you don't just
need the right food and enrichment but
also trees terrain and all kinds of
other scenery elements that you might
add which i think is really cool
especially when it comes to foliage and
I think here too it works really well at
the scenery UI from planet coaster
planet coaster is always had this system
where you can filter out certain objects
based on which content pack they're from
or which kind of scenery they are or
even based on custom tags and this is a
system that's never really worked that
well in planet coaster I think there are
some questionable choices as to where
certain scenery pieces belong the custom
tags are actually really great but also
this whole filtering has never been an
absolute must-have in planet coaster I
think but I think in Planet Zoo it's
become much more important because it's
a real gameplay elements and it helps
you figure out it's you know I'm
building this animal this is what part
of the world they're from this is the
kind of biome that they need and then
based on that you can filter out all of
the scenery elements and get just the
right foliage into that habitat which is
just a really nice touch and finally I
just really like the way that weather
interacts with scenery as well I really
didn't expect weather to look this good
I remember that there were many
conversations around planet coaster
people always wanted to have weather and
planet coaster and time and time again
the devs well they had to say that it
was just not doable because there are so
many things to keep in mind when
everything is piece-by-piece built and
you
have dynamic weather it's just it's very
complicated and the fact that there is
weather like this in Planet Zoo the fact
that rain splashes on flat surfaces
force all the sides of roofs the fact
that snow covers basically everything
and then leaves everything that's
covered dry it's absolutely amazing and
on Rudy rent kemal stream
he built a giant aviary out of well
stone pillars brick pillars on the sides
of the aviary and these brick pillars
kind of curved as they went up so they
started vertical at the bottom and then
curved to more diagonal slope at the top
and the cool thing is that there was
noticeably more snow on these things at
the top and the diagonal sections and
then on the vertical parts all the way
at the bottom the snow only settled in
the mortar between the bricks which is
absolutely amazing
I wasn't even expecting snow to settle
on the ground let alone then it settles
you know on the sides of vertical
textures so you know and I think this is
something that people are definitely
going to take for granted once the game
has been out for a while but the fact
that scenery interacts with or the fact
that weather interacts with scenery in
this way is absolutely crucial and I
also just like doing that animals
interact with this again the fact that
they will flee from rain collar heats
depending on where they're from what the
weather is like and then use piece by
piece built structures as shelter is
really cool so yeah what I'd say in the
end is that the one thing that I really
like about the game is that you know at
least so far it seems like making a park
run well can be a combination of making
it well managed and making it look good
and it's not like these are two
different goals that you have to look
after this at different times but it's
really you know there's a single
objective in a sense and scenery and
management are always things that I've
considered sort of a balance to things
on both sides of the scale but this game
might just prove that it can be
nation as well to an extent that I
haven't seen much in sandbox games so
far so that's something that I find
really interesting and positive about my
impression so far now there are some
other things that are noteworthy and
firstly I'm first gonna list some
smaller things that I found notable and
then I'll come to the footage that
you're looking at right now which I
should probably do at some point as well
so first of all the foliage is
absolutely beautiful I'm really happy
about that a lack of foliage was always
one of my main gripes with the planet
coaster and they've more than
compensated for it in this game which i
think makes sense as well since this is
a zoo game and having fauna you know
having the right flora is also really
important and there seems to be a much
wider variety of trees and bushes from
different biomes all of them look very
crisp and realistic compared to planet
coasters foliage I did notice that there
are certain trees and bushes that are
coming back from Planet goes to but all
of them have gotten new models new
textures and just look a bit better I
didn't notice a single foliage piece
that was exactly the same maybe I just
looked over it because I didn't play the
game that much but my impression anyway
is really good the tall grass is really
beautiful as well so altogether I think
that's a positive
I've seen some criticism about a lack of
variation very often you only have two
or three trees of a certain type for
variation so it is true if you don't
watch out with that gyro you'll make it
very obvious that every tree is just a
copy but then again if you keep rotating
them mixing it up a little bit I think
it'll be very doable to just make
believable
forests and biomes and habitats it's
also something to keep in mind that all
of these trees are interacted with my
animals and respond to weather so I can
kind of see why the amount of trees is
limited and I also want to note the
building pieces I think overall the
textures are a bit more realistic than
in planet coaster
and different scents seem to fit well
together and altogether I think the
whole style of the game that they seem
to go for with the foliage and the new
building pieces is a bit less cartoony
then planet goes to which of my eyes is
a positive as well the weather effects
are amazing
obviously not too much I can really say
about that
the scenery with physics that animals
can actually play with is really cool
the fact that you can throw toys for
enrichment in habitats and they will
really roll off hills and animals will
pick them up is really cool and I know
this is also kind of a basic thing and
something you would expect from a zoo
game but the fact that you know the
physics was completely absent from
scenery in planet coaster just kind of
makes me very excited about this even
the poop rolls off the head of the hills
and it looks wet in the rain which is a
beautiful detail one thing that's a bit
of a bummer is that you can no longer
terraform around bodies of water like
you could in planet coaster but I also
have to say that this is probably a
trade off or the ability to put water
inside the habitat walls right the
volumetric water because in planet
coaster water wasn't volumetric you
could just build a small pond and then
edit the edges as you want it with the
terraforming tool but in Planet 2 as
soon as the water is in somewhere you
can edit the terraforming around it
anymore so if you really want to change
the shape of that lake or pond you have
to take the water out I think and then
move stuff around and put it back in
which is a bit of a bummer but then
again it's I think it's it's a net gain
if we're able to put water in site
habitat walls and have glass walls
underneath water in habitats or built
custom fountains even or things like
that now finally I wanted to discuss
some of the things which I've shown in
this video and a lot of other youtubers
have already
focused on this so I wanted to just make
it a small part of this video but we've
got a bunch of new animals the ones that
are actually in habitats or the Indian
Rhino is the mandrills which I'm adding
some climbing elements for here
the Himalayan bears Burt stop ears gary
owls which is the crocodiles with a
super lengthy snout which I'm fixing the
water supply for here and the pronghorn
antelope
which you can see shares its habitat
with Springboks that's something that
somebody on the planet sued this court
was asking question about and yeah I
think it wasn't too much showing off in
the planet coaster live stream but yeah
these guys share that habitat which is
pretty neat and also what's really cool
is the Indian subcontinent theme which I
think looks great I think it's based on
in the Islamic or in those ceramic
architecture it's kind of difficult to
tell but these are very eclectic and
flexible architectural styles so I'm
really happy about that because I think
it could probably be used for Middle
Eastern or North African themed habitats
and areas as well there's just so much
detail and that and it's an overall
architectural style which I thought was
kind of underrepresented in planet goes
through and especially with this being a
game where you want to be able to
represent pretty much any part of the
world I think it's really cool to see
this kind of architecture in here and
finally I think it's notable that there
are a lot of recoverable wall pieces in
this map during the gamescom live
streams I saw a lot of people asking
about recolor ability of pieces because
many of the pieces in the demo build and
the lifestream build during Gamescom had
very yeah few ree colorable options and
but yeah i think that's just something
related to the british and generic theme
that was in that in that build of the
game because the building sets in this
map show a lot of recolor ball building
pieces and I have to say recolor ability
is a bit of a trade off as well
recoverable items always have no
slightly less nuances slightly less
detail
on the textures then non-recoverable
items so I think for brick was things
like that it's quite all right
to have no recoverable options although
I suppose the best situation would be to
have a non recoverable wall and then a
another recolor ball kind of similar
piece with just a different texture that
recolor is better the only thing that
I'm a bit concerned about here is I do
hope that those brown pieces are
recoverable as well but aside from that
the whole set looks entirely recoverable
so that's good anyway those were all my
thoughts about planets ooh based on
Gamescom I know there's a lot of things
that I didn't really touch upon like the
electricity or water management's or
certain elements of managing animals and
stuff but these are really just general
things that I thought have been much
more talked about in other live streams
other YouTube content and by frontier
themselves this video is just some of
the things that stuck out most to me but
yeah I do wonder if you guys have
anything that you really want me to know
about or want to have my opinion about
then feel free to ask or tell me about
anything in the comment section and I'd
like to thank you guys for watching and
hopefully I'll see you in some planets
do video in the future not quite sure
when that's going to be but it's
definitely going to happen at some point
and I'll be playing the beta as well
anyway bye guys